my research clearly comes from my own
personal experiences and what who I am
and where I grew up and I think this is
the case for a lot of social scientists
in my case I was born in Europe to Dutch
parents I actually never lived in the
Netherlands as a young child we moved
around to a number of countries we live
briefly in Greece and Spain and in
England and then we migrated to Canada
when I was quite young I didn't speak a
word of English but quickly learned as a
young child went through the public
school system in Canada through to
university and then moved down to the
United States and have been a professor
in the University of California Berkeley
for the last eight years also during
that time I lived for a year in France
and I lived for a year in the
Netherlands and so all of those
migration experiences have definitely
made me someone who is very attentive to
issues of migration and identity and I
sometimes don't know how to answer this
question who are you and so last year
when I was in the Netherlands I was on
sabbatical and affiliated with the
Center for ethnic and migration studies
at the University of Amsterdam people
would ask me well where are you from and
it would be a very hard answer and so I
finally came down to I am North American
of Dutch background but it's a hard
thing to do and I think it's going to
get increasingly hard as people just
become even more mobile at the same time
in the u.s. context I continue to say
that I'm Canadian even though it's been
16 years that I haven't lived there